en este hospital en estrasburgo el
personal de salud es testigo de una
cuarta ola de contagios de coronavirus
que avanza lentamente en menos de dos
semanas el número de pacientes admitidos
en esta unidad pasó de 2 a 18 tenemos
una sensación de que se viene una
tormenta que podemos escuchar retumbar
los truenos y que en unos días y semanas
muchos pacientes serán hospitalizados
últimamente en nuestra unidad admitimos
a una persona de 30 años y otra de 40
estima todos los pacientes no estaban
vacunados entre perfeccione el aumento
en casos llegue en un momento en el que
el personal de salud está máxima
capacidad por la temporada de vacaciones
de verano estamos todos cansados hemos
tenido momentos difíciles pero tenemos
un gran equipo unido el codo y también
nos ha fortalecido ayer nuevos casos
confirmados han ido en aumento llegando
a 20.000 en toda francia en esta semana
el gobierno reportó un incremento de
nuevos contagios diarios de un 90 por
ciento en los últimos siete días y un
aumento del 74 por ciento en el número
de admitidos en unidades de cuidados
intensivos